I want to see a movie with a bunch of Poogles
and faerie Aishas.
That's what I want.
Give it to me.
I don't know what's happening.
This is-
I'm talking about Neopets.
She had an aneurysm.
I've only...
Yeah.
I taste pennies.
Is that normal?
Nina, what's a great film that you are glad
never got a sequel?
Well Brian, I was looking at the article of
that same title on a little website called
Looper.com and-
I've heard of that website.
Yeah.
As have I and yeah.
It has so many movies that I love very much
on it and that I agree with wholeheartedly.
I'm thrilled that Casablanca does not have
Casablanca 2 Back in Morocco or whatever.
Casas Blancas.
Yeah.
I'm glad Inception didn't continue because
it closes on such a good button.
Pulp Fiction is a long time favorite and I
don't even want to think about what a sequel
would've been and I ended up going with something
on the list, but I want to present my honorable
mention first because it's a movie that I
love very much, that was a huge comedy hit
and that I believe there have been many attempts
to wring a sequel out of it, but they haven't
been successful because the screenwriters
just don't want to do it and they're smart
and that's Bridesmaids, which was a huge hit,
crushed the box office, great reviews, was
nominated for Academy Awards for Melissa McCarthy
and for screenplay written by Kristen Wiig
and her friend, Annie Mumolo.
And I believe that the powers that be behind
Bridesmaids have wanted a sequel for years
because of how profitable it was, but Kristen
Wiig and Annie Mumolo have just been like,
"No, we're done.
We're done telling that story.
Let it rest," and I'm really happy because
I think a sequel would probably be about Maya
Rudolph's character having a baby and it would
just play the same beats of the first one.
And I don't think it would be good-
... another Hangover.
What if they called it Brides and they all
got married at the same time?
That would be bad, Brian.
That would be a bad movie that I don't want
to see.
No, it's like-
... bad, Brian.
I don't see a way that they could avoid The
Hangover curse of that where they just do
the same thing for three movies to increasingly
diminishede returns and also, what that led to
is instead of working on Bridesmaids 2, Brides,
or whatever your idea was-
Groomsmen.
Yeah, Groomsmen.
Finally, a comedy like this for the guys!
Oh, it's been so long.
But what this led to is Kristen Wiig and-
Nina, we're talking.
Brian, that's a really good idea.
What this led to, I'm going to continue with
some dignity left maybe, is-
Sorry.
... because Kristen Wiig and Annie Mumolo
had an Oscar nomination under their belt and
a ton of financial studio success, they got
to make the weirdest movie of 2020, near and
dear to my heart, Barb and Star Go to-
Barb and Star Go to Vista Del Mar.
Yes and I consider that a spiritual sequel
to Bridesmaids and if you haven't seen it,
please watch it.
I think it's on Hulu right now.
If you don't think that you want to see Jamie
Dornan dancing down a beach and doing pirouettes
and singing his heart out, then you're just
wrong.
You're very wrong.
You do want to see that, but okay.
My real pick.
I got off topic is Social Network.
Okay.
My real pick is The Social Network, which
is one of my all time favorite movies.
Everyone who knows me pretty well knows that
I have a really bitter grudge against King's
Speech, which is a fine movie, but it should
not have beaten Social Network for best picture
and I will die on that hill.
That's fair.
Should have just called The King Speech.
Lost the The.
Yeah.
That's fair.
It's cleaner.
Did you just whack your mic?
Anyway, I'm going to continue as if nothing
happened.
Please.
No.
Social Network should have been a best picture
winner.
No, a very acclaimed movie, great cast, great
writing, great direction.
Everything about it comes together.
It's such a tightly paced and edited and just
every aspect of the movie, I think for me,
works on every single level and it also is
smart in that it specifically focuses on the
inception in college years of Facebook, rather
than the modern behemoth that Facebook has
become and with all the weird, legal troubles
that whole company has faced in the past couple
of years through elections and through all
sorts of stuff, I mean I don't want to see
that continue.
That would be a really upsetting and potentially
very dull movie.
I mean, there's going to be a documentary
about it eventually that I'll watch and talk
about at a dinner party or whatever, but it's
not a sequel I want to see and I also think
that none of the people would come back for
it.
So, it would just be very bad.
It would be some you cut rate Aaron Sorkin
acolyte and someone who looks like Jesse Eisenberg,
but isn't him.
Michael Cera.
Yeah.
I didn't want to say Michael Cera because
I wanted to give him a little more credit
than that, but you're right.
It would be Michael Cera.
Poor Michael Cera.
Yeah.
Yes.
It would be him and Tom Holland as Andrew
Garfield, yeah, to play Eduardo.
I'm starting to think this movie might be
good.
I don't know.
Can we do exactly what we're talking about
here, but it's the origin of MySpace?
Who's going to play Tom?
I think Bradley Cooper should play Tom from
MySpace.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, no.
That's what I'm saying.
Bring in Michael, bring in the off brand,
bring in the Kirkland Signature versions of
all of the actors.
The story of Friendster.
Yeah.
The story of Xanga and LiveJournal.
This is Neopets.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
No.
Now you're just describing a bunch of movies
I want to watch is the problem.
I would totally watch a gritty, biopic about
the founding of Neopets.
Of course I'd watch that.
That sounds awesome.
I think Scientology was involved in that eventually.
It was-
... Christian Bale in there.
I'm sure I can find a link and we can put
it in the description, but there is a long
form YouTube video about the weird shady stuff
behind Neopets and it's fascinating.
Yeah.
Neopets was a big touchstone for me.
So, yeah.
Social Network, I don't want to see remade
unless it's about Myspace, Friendster, Xanga,
LiveJournal or Neopets, in which case I want
to see it.
Club Penguin?
I want to see a movie with a bunch of Poogles
and faerie Aishas.
That's what I want.
Give it to me.
I don't know what's happening.
This is all-
I'm talking about Neopets.
She had an aneurysm.
I've only, yeah.
Yeah.
I taste Pennies.
Is that normal?
No.
Get them out of your mouth.
There's a couple on this article that I responded
to.
One was Logan Lucky, which I saw pretty recently,
which I liked a bunch.
That was a good heist movie and I do agree
that I think a sequel to that would definitely
diminish some of the special weirdness that
happens in that film.
It's a fun movie.
It's a really fun movie and a lot of that
has to do with Daniel Craig playing Joe Bang,
which also brings up this interesting...
We've talked about this before, the sequel
to Knives Out, Knives In.
I love- Yep.
More Knives-
Knives Out Two, Knife Crimes.
Yeah.
Knife Crimes.
You're welcome.
I think I just blew a booger out of my nose.
Thank you.
Knife Crimes.
You're welcome.
Inside jokes, they happen here too.
No, but the reason I bring it up, right?
Because Daniel Craig plays Benoit Blanc and
he's amazing.
I love that movie.
I'm really excited to see a sequel, but part
of me also likes to think that would've been
great as just a standalone film that you can
just revisit and say, "Do you want more Knives
Out?
Watch the movie again.
Here it is.
There's no chance that it will disappoint
you because it's the same movie it was that
you like."
I mean, I will make the rebuttal though that
I like the idea of the Agatha Christie, Hercule
Poirot thing that they're clearly doing with
Benoit Blanc where it's like put him in a
different situation, he'll be himself and
then you get a cast of A-listers to surround
him.
Right.
No, I agree.
I'm excited to see what they do, but I do
think back to movies like Logan Lucky that
are so singular, so weird and that definitely
could have sequels.
It has franchise potential, but unfortunately
for them, unfortunately for us, it didn't
do very well.
So, they're not going to make one.
So, you just have this one strange, Southern
Gothic comedy, heist film and it just works.
And the other one that you mentioned was Inception,
which is a really good example of a great
movie that again, has that sequel potential.
You could go in all different directions with
it and thank goodness that they didn't.
Well I mean, aside from Batman, I don't think
Christopher Nolan's much in the sequel business.
Is he?
I mean-
No.
Fair enough.
But I mean, that's the thing-
I can't think of a single movie he's made
that's not Batman that has a sequel.
Beyond that too though-
He did that sequel to The Prestige where it
was just Hugh Jackman's body floating in a
tank the whole time.
Oh.
I missed that one.
Yeah.
Very Warholesk.
That sounds great.
Yikes.
No, but one of the things that's so great
about Inception is that ending, which is that
people like to know is he in a dream?
Is he not in a dream?
Did it wobble?
Did it fall?
Did it fall after the screen went to blank?
And the answer ultimately is it doesn't matter
because the ending is the ending is the ending.
That's how the movie ends.
I think we can all agree that none of us want
to see what happens when and if the top stops
spinning.
It's-
Wouldn't that be great if the sequel was just
the top spinning for 90 minutes?
Honestly, I would not put that past Sir Christopher
Nolan.
I don't think he's a knight.
I'm just calling him that anyway, but-
He will be.
Yeah.
That wouldn't surprise me at all-
Or they do it like Clue where there's two
different movies, right?
Yeah.
The top is spinning for 90 minutes and the
other one is the top falls immediately and
it's just laying on a table for 90 minutes.
By the way, that's also a movie I'm glad didn't
get a sequel, is Clue.
A perfect film-
Another good one.
Yeah.
Another good example of a great movie and
again, Clue is the kind of thing that you
could do 100 times and it would be different
every time and it would be fun and funny and
great every time.
Although you couldn't do that movie again
because that cast is perfect-
No.
It's lightning in a bottle and much like Logan
Lucky, it was a flop and so, they were never
going to make a sequel because it did so poorly.
Right.
An incredible flop that nobody at the time
liked and weirdos like us watched it on TV
throughout our whole lives-
And it became a cult classic and now Flames
on the Side of my Face is the greatest gif
ever made.
Yeah.
I just love to see, I love the little bit
where Martin Mull's like, "Does anyone want
to drink?"
And a bunch of people want drinks and he just
pours booze all over the class-
I just like anything Madeline Kahn does in
that whole movie, like when she just runs
around making-
Or any movie.
... squeaky noises - or any movie.
Yeah, she's perfect.
Yeah.
No.
Logan Lucky's a good one.
Logan Lucky, Inception, Clue, Clueless...
I don't want to see that sequel where she
and Josh break up in college.
Although they did have a TV spinoff.
So-
I know.
I watched it.
So, now that brings up a good point because
a lot of the movies that we've been talking
about and I only bring this up...
By the way, just side note.
Just an idea for later, maybe we all get a
button called the comment blocker where it
makes a loud noise and we're allowed to interrupt
each other when we just want to correct.
We don't want to be rude, but we need to correct
something really quickly because we know that
the YouTube comment section is going to fill
up with ---- talking.
Actually I think what really happened, Casablanca
had a TV show.
They made a TV show following up The Adventures
of Rick in his part, at Rick's.
That sucks.
What was the...
Yeah, no.
It does suck and I don't know if it made it
past pilot, but-
And I will say, I did.
I watched the Clueless series, but it was
bad.
Donald Faison was on it and the girl who played
Amber was on it and I think those were the
only two people who came back from the movie,
but it was a bad show.
People who liked paychecks.
Yeah, man.
The name of the Casablanca TV show is called
Casablanca.
How original.
It was from 1983.
So you mentioned a few movies, but I don't
think you've gone into any of your picks.
So, what are some movies that you are glad
don't have sequels?
Speaking to what we were talking about, the
one that I picked that comes off of the article
that we have.
It is something that there have been other
projects associated with it, there have been
unofficial sequels to it and a lot of plays
and it helps it.
I think it whoops into the public domain a
while ago, but It's a Wonderful Life.
It's a Wonderful Life.
Classic movie, beautiful ending, wonderful
story.
Any continuation of it that I can think of
aside from doing-
A comedy version-
I was thinking a series.
Yeah.
Waka Waka.
No, totally.
Right, but unless you turned it into an anthology
series where it's angels going around.
Well, that's Touched by an Angel, which is
a perfect show that nobody ever had any complaints
about.
I was thinking about, I was trying to figure
out how you would do a sequel to It's a Wonderful
Life and the unfortunate fact of the matter
is that it's a story about a guy who is told
by God that he's pretty good.
That he's a pretty great dude and I can't
imagine that does anything good to a person's
psyche, right?
There's no way that he became a better person
because of that, right?
That's a lot of confidence to pile onto one
dude.
So, I feel like if we caught up with that
character later on...
No, please.
I mean, the premise of The Good Place though
is that a godlike figure tells somebody you're
great and you belong in the good place and
he's using that false information to torture
her and then she eventually becomes a better
person, as do all the rest of them.
Right.
Well, he's doing that specifically to torture
her though.
This is more like-
Right, but then they actually all put in the
work-
God feels sorry for a guy.
So he's like, "Hey man.
I bet you're all right.
I bet you're okay."
Yeah, you're okay.
There's other implications to it too.
Clarence, the angel that gets sent down.
Pretty clearly a barely functional alcoholic
throughout the whole thing, right?
And then they give him wings and-
Isn't the implication in that, that guardian
angels do that kind of thing all the time?
Yeah-
And that this is the action that gives them
their wings?
So I mean right there, you have an It's a
Wonderful Life cinematic universe already
unfolding.
Oh boy.
Totally.
Yeah.
It sounds boring and bad, but yeah.
I mean, someone-
It really only works once.
Yeah.
Really nice story, but I don't know.
There's nowhere to take that, right?
At best, you find out that...
I don't know.
Well and it's also, I mean Tom, you mentioned
what a sweet, heartwarming story it is and
so, yeah.
A sequel at any time about any member of the
family would feel so soulless, like what a
cash grab it would be.
That's the bigger thing for me.
Here's how you do a sequel.
George Bailey is dead.
He is now an angel assigned to It's a Wonderful
Life someone, But he's really not good at
it and people keep jumping to their deaths.
So, then they resend a new angel to show George
that things would be much worse if he weren't
an angel.
Isn't this also just the plot of Soul?
I don't remember.
Wait a minute.
So, are you saying that they send an angel
to convince George that the world is better
with the people that he got killed dead?
Yeah.
Like he's an angel of death that's going down
and inadvertently pushing people over the
edge and forcing them-
I have an idea.
I haven't really thought it through.
What if he finds dead people and they whisper,
"Help me," and then they get transported back
to the day of their death?
As God as my witness.
Nina, if you pitch Tru Calling one more time.
I will never stop pitching Tru Calling.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single video.
We love you.
Bye.